did Joe Biden legitimately win the 2022  election against Donald Trump yeah  actually he did win the election but the  big question is he does he know that  that's that's what I wonder sometimes  but I want to talk about about he being  who  Joe Biden  what do you mean by that well I I yes I  agree that he won the election but I  wonder sometimes if he actually realizes  that he's president of the United States  of course he recognize these and that's  why you're insulting the president  United States of course he understands  he's president  God what a loser  um  silence  silence one of the most awkward silences  of the entire debate season there